[Music]
at the beginning of the film we are
introduced to a wealthy businessman
named jen he owns several businesses
most of which are restaurants jyn is a
culinary art enthusiast and is very
particular about the foods sold in his
restaurants he spends hours tasting
dishes served by famous chefs to make
them perfect through the years he has
developed a unique talent where he can
tell what ingredients a dish is made of
just by smelling it one day he goes to a
five-star hotel that he is looking to
buy the first dish he has served is the
famous beef wellington which is a
specialty of the head chef jin tries a
bite and spits it out saying that the
type of mushroom used in the dish is
wrong similarly he has served a plethora
of different dishes all of which are the
chef's specials however each of them has
one drawback or another that
dissatisfies him by the end of the hour
the head chef runs out of ideas and
feels helpless the staff also has no
clue how to impress someone as picky as
jen
this is when we are introduced to a
young chef named shang nan although she
is just an intern her knowledge of
worldwide culinary styles is impeccable
and she is soon to be promoted because
of her talent even though they have only
20 minutes left before jyn leaves
shangnon takes the challenge to make him
something he likes none of the staff
members think she can pull it off but
right after 20 minutes jyn has a new
dish on his table when he smells the
first whiff of the food his eyes open
wide he recognizes it as the special
romani dish named spaghetti alastrega
jyn can even tell that the cook is a
woman because the dish is passed down to
females of romani origin the spices must
be very carefully measured because it is
a traditional dish that doesn't allow
any personal spin on it shangnan has
made it exactly how it is supposed to be
which gains jen's appreciation he cleans
the plate dry and decides to stay at the
hotel for a few days to taste more of
her dishes the manager tells shangnan
about jyn's comment making her realize
that he has a vast knowledge of food she
takes it as a challenge and is ready to
blow his mind with her cooking shangnan
is also dating the restaurant's general
manager he takes advantage of her
position and makes her cook food for him
even on the days she is busy one
afternoon after enjoying everything she
made for him he reveals that he wants to
break up because she is too skinny for
his liking shangnan is heartbroken but
she knows there's no point in arguing
later that day jyn is on his way out
when he notices her sitting on his car's
hood he doesn't recognize her as the
chef since he's never seen her face
shangnan thinks the car belongs to her
ex-boyfriend and scratches it to teach
him a lesson when jyn calls her out she
realizes she came to the wrong floor she
quickly apologizes and promises to paint
it like new at night shangnon gets drunk
and climbs on the roof at the same time
jyn is making ramen in his room he
believes that even the two minute noodle
is a difficult dish to make since one
has to measure the ingredients and time
precisely just when he is about to take
a bite someone falls on his balcony it
is none other than the drunk shangnan
who has fallen from the roof when she
refuses to go out jyn puts her into a
suitcase and keeps her inside the
elevator she is found by two staff
members who go into a frenzy assuming
that she is a dead body in the following
scene jyn is locked inside a cell with
other criminals shangnan is outside
explaining what happened to the
policeman a while later jyn's assistant
arrives and bails him out jin hopes to
never meet shangnan again but they cross
paths the very next day shangnong is
helping some kids when she accidentally
touches a beehive the bees attack gin
making his face swell having had enough
of her he gives her a watch that will
alert him if she is near him shangnon
promises to run away as soon as she
hears the alarm starting the next day
jyn orders several dishes to test the
chef's talent shangnan impresses him
with every single dish but jyn is still
unaware that she is the same girl he
wants to stay away from with time he
starts ordering food that is not even on
the menu shangnon works until midnight
and is very tired but jin doesn't show
signs of exhaustion hence she puts squid
ink on one of the dishes symbolizing
that she is running away jyn understands
the message and stops ordering food for
the night he also sends her a letter
asking her to be a good opponent instead
of running away the following day jyn
has to appear in an interview the
interviewer asks him questions about the
suitcase scandal making him
uncomfortable at the same time shangnan
finds out the picky client is none other
than the same guy she has to stay away
from scared that her watch will ring she
tries to run but falls into the swimming
pool for the next meal jyn wants
shangnan to showcase her creativity
instead of the name of the dishes he
sends her three themes that she is free
to interpret however she likes the
themes are a time a place and a moment
for the first theme changnon makes
extremely spicy seafood indicating
summertime jyn has a hard time eating
anything spicy but is happy that she
nailed the theme the second one is the
place in this dish jyn can smell
rosemary which reminds him of a
lighthouse by the sea he realizes it is
a depiction of shanghai then for the
last dish she makes pork with matcha
seasoning that jyn associates with the
japanese tea ceremony he is beyond
impressed by shangnan's talent while
shangnan is impressed that he could
figure out exactly what she was trying
to portray with each dish for the
dessert she requests to make an original
dish it is a sweet cake made up of
ingredients that are typically from the
us canada and the uk these are the three
places that jyn has lived in over the
years so he understands that it
represents him however there is a
truffle on the side that takes him by
surprise he asks the waiter to bring the
chef so she can explain its meaning
personally afraid to face him shangnan
sends the head chef outside with her
message he reveals that the truffle
grows underground and eats everything
around it to maintain its power shangnan
believes jen is like a truffle which is
why she made it jyn refuses to believe
the head chef and goes looking for
shangnan but she runs away before he
finds her a while later they bump into
each other in the bathroom jyn smells
the scent of food from her and
recognizes her as the chef who has been
cooking for him the following day at
work he turns off his watch and catches
her cooking in the restaurant's kitchen
shangnan has to reluctantly admit that
she is his chef she also affirms that
the truffle was to symbolize his
arrogance jyn gives it a thought and
praises her for understanding him better
than he understands himself later he is
in his room when he gets a call from his
father mr liu the man is so business
oriented that he frequently fails to be
a father to jen lou urges him to return
to work as he has spent a lot of time in
a single hotel the next morning jyn
calls the room service to order his
first meal of the day however he is told
shangnan is on sick leave not wanting to
eat food cooked by anyone else he goes
straight to her apartment he has even
brought all the necessary ingredients so
she can make the dish that he wants her
to her home is messy but jin declutters
and sets himself a table while she cooks
shangnan is still weirded out by his
appearance but she sits down with him to
eat to her surprise he asks her to eat
in the kitchen because he prefers eating
alone she curses him for being arrogant
before doing is told when she comes out
a while later she finds jyn taking a nap
on her couch he has a hard time falling
asleep anywhere else but for some reason
her couch is very comfortable jyn wakes
up hours later and finds shangnan
sleeping on her bed the next day he
comes again and makes her cook a
different dish after eating he falls
asleep again on the third day he comes
with a sheet to cover the couch to make
it more comfortable as the days pass he
starts bringing pajamas and his personal
belongings all this time shangnan can
hardly fall asleep because of his
snoring and has a hard time at work
because of it one afternoon jyn allows
her to eat with him and the two enjoy a
long meal together they also eat
blowfish for the first time unaware that
it makes people high soon the two feel
its effects and hallucinate that it is
raining they stay under an umbrella even
when indoors and talk about several
things that make no sense a while later
they go out for a walk still thinking
that it is raining when the weather is
completely dry then they end up inside a
bus where jyn's high wears off he
realizes that people are looking at him
and asks shangnan to put the umbrella
down she doesn't listen to him still
affected by the high by the end of the
night jyn brings her home and tucks her
in cut to two days later shangnan hasn't
seen him since they last ate together he
has also checked out of the hotel which
worries her deciding to check up on him
she arrives at his home to her surprise
he is enjoying a meal made by his
personal chef of seven years the women
instantly see each other as rivals and
try to prove how important they are to
jinn in the end an infuriated shangnan
storms off in anger the next day the
other chef comes to meet shangnan at
work and asks her to be an assistant
chef for jyn shangnon refuses asking her
to go away at night jyn comes to her
apartment to apologize but drives away
at the last minute he has never felt
close to anyone in his life other than
shangnan which is why he is scared of
losing her but he doesn't understand
that it is love and he pulls away he
goes to the restaurant the next day and
fires all the kitchen employees he has
decided to buy the hotel but since it
doesn't live up to their standard
management-wise their company has
decided to use it for something else jyn
tries to talk to shangnan but she
doesn't want to listen to a word he has
to say during dinner jyn asks his chef
to join him she is surprised because
over the course of seven years he has
never asked her to eat she reveals that
she only made one portion like she
always does after she leaves jyn gets a
message from her saying that she cannot
be more than a personal chef to him jyn
has to catch a flight in a few hours he
wants to see shangnan before leaving but
decides against it in the following
scene he is with his father who is
disappointed in him for letting his
personal interests get in the way of
business they have a meal together and
jyn asks mr liu if he has ever been in
love with someone his father answers
that he doesn't indulge in anything that
doesn't support his business at this
moment jyn registers he doesn't want to
be like his father he takes the next
flight to shanghai to meet shangnan
again meanwhile she is about to sell the
watch he gave her long ago suddenly it
starts to ring indicating his presence
shangnan sees him on the other side of
the road and promptly gets in a taxi she
doesn't want to face him or talk to him
jyn on the other hand is stubborn he
follows the taxi and ends up in a
crowded market upon taking the watch's
signal he finds shangnan's dog with it
then the dog brings him to a place where
shangnon has locked herself inside she
refuses to talk to him but her interest
peaks when he mentions that she is the
only friend he has had in life he
confesses his love and asks her to come
outside shangnan even makes him say that
she is the sexiest person in the world
after the interaction they go to her
apartment building but jyn brings her to
a different apartment because it has a
better view of the sky the movie ends as
they watch the sunset together the moral
of this creepy story is that as long as
you're rich you will literally always
get your way
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching